fighting between Ukraine government
forces and separatists has intensified
in the country's East following Russia's
recognition of breakaway regions
shelling attacks have picked up in the
provinces of luhansk and dunetsk that's
where separatists declare their own
republics in 2014. they now control
large chunks of each region Moscow says
its recognition of the self-declared
states extends to territory now held by
Ukrainian forces setting up the
possibility of further sanctions
residents have been caught in the
crossfire between Ukraine and the
separatists our correspondent Matthias
Berlinger filed this report from the
front line
it is quiet at the moment a good time to
leave for days now the people in the
village of rubika have been under Fire
the villages in Ukrainian
government-controlled territory and is
being shelled by separatists from the
other side
we have been up the whole night some
people are still in the cellar too
scared to come out
the kids spent the whole day yesterday
downstairs but at night we went upstairs
it was just too cold downstairs a Cellar
is a seller
half of the village has already left the
others are terrified shells have come
down right in the center of the village
one shall hit the schoolyard while
children were in class
others have damaged people's homes
luckily no one has been hurt so far but
the constant stress has taken its toll
electricity and gas have been cut off
now gas workers have come to patch up
some of the damage
we fixed the pipe twice already we came
last week yesterday and today we're here
again rubika is quite far away from the
artillery positions of the other side
there are 15 kilometers between here and
the front line which is just the range
of this artillery that they are using
people here have not experienced this
kind of fighting even during the worst
times a few years ago
okay
and her neighbors have tried to make the
most out of the cold and damp Cellar but
the effect of the electric heater is
limited
she is in and out of the basement
constantly those days
I need to go up now to take some stuff
to my daughter's place she is finally
leaving with her kids at least to a
place nearby
she would like her to move further away
until it becomes clear with the latest
news from Moscow and Kiev mean
I don't know what to think now
yeah
I do not yet understand
I don't even know what to do next
it takes just a few minutes and the
shelling begins again
Let's cross over now to our
correspondent Fanny phatra in Kiev funny
tell us more about what's happening
along that line of contact in eastern
Ukraine where government forces and
separatist forces are clashing
and that line tarries 400 kilometers
long and it's really difficult to
actually get just the full picture of
what's happening but as my colleague
Matthias Bollinger just pointed out in
his report it's actually civilians who
are already bearing the brand or the on
the Ukrainian side this one Village that
experiences shelling and people's
uncertainty and the feeling of what to
do next how should they prepare if if
the situation is likely to worsen now
the Ukrainian military said giving some
numbers there that according to the
information there have been 96 incidents
of shellings that led to one soldier
being killed and several being injured
that's up from 84 incidents of shelling
just the day before unfortunately we do
not expect the situation to be in any
way a
decreasing intention but rather
increasing especially as we hear from
Russia that this is this is this seems
to be just the beginning even though
they have declared the independence of
luhansk and Donetsk they is more to come
that it's not just going to be stay
staying with that one third of eastern
Ukraine but this very much interested in
the rest of the donbass region as well
the Ukrainian President says he's not
mobilizing the country's entire military
at this point but he is calling up
reservists for the Armed Forces how are
people there reacting to that
in a way they say it's just about time
that actually Ukraine is trying to face
the facts and maybe the inevitable that
they have to face Another War here while
others are again hoping that because
there's no General mobilization yet
there still may be the door open to some
diplomacy to some negotiation to find a
peaceful resolution a peaceful solution
to all of this people in Kiev who've
been who I've been talking to just last
week could not even imagine that there
may be an assault on their capital a few
days later with politics changing with
decision making from Russia about the
recognition of those two uh separatist
regions as independent states people are
starting to change their mind and they
are growing concerned over the day they
really are hoping there is a peaceful
way out of this but they're actually
preparing for the worst and not just the
adults but they are also preparing their
children for that telling them where to
go in case there is an assault here
telling them to write on a piece of
paper their blood type their address in
case when a shelling starts even here in
Kiev that the children know where to go
and where to ask help
funny you say that Kiev has not given up
hope for diplomacy I know that Kiev has
not cut off diplomatic relations with
Moscow for example what options does the
government there see for resolving this
diplomatically given moscow's latest
moves
given that sanctions have been announced
and even imposed already by the West
also Japan Australia Australia wants to
impose sanctions on Russia it kind of
gives this feeling of of perspective for
Ukraine that the sanctions may actually
bring about some change and stop Russia
from further uh going into into Ukraine
nobody knows actually whether that's the
case because Russia already signaled
that they find sanctions such as
blackmailing and the West is going to
keep sanctioning Russia until they're
exhausted with it but Ukraine wants to
maintain at least for this moment still
that there's a peaceful way out of all
of this even though really nobody knows
what the next hours are going to bring
here for Ukraine and the ukrainians
funny thank you very much our
correspondent panipata in Kiev
well Russia appears to be continuing its
military buildup along Ukraine's borders
U.S satellite images claimed to show in
a large base in southern Belarus just a
few hundred kilometers from the
Ukrainian Capital Kia President Joe
Biden says Russia's invasion of Ukraine
has already begun
Russian troops are on the move
they're heading towards Ukraine's
eastern border
fighting intensifies between Ukrainian
and separatist forces
far away from the front line the Upper
House of the Russian Parliament voted to
authorize the use of force outside
Russia's borders they also approved
Vladimir Putin's recognition of the
Donetsk and luhansk people's republics
as independent states
but the Russian president didn't stop
there he later announced the borders of
the two republics include the
ukrainian-held territories not just the
rebel-held areas
people's republics which means we have
recognized all their founding documents
including the Constitution and the
Constitution defines the borders of the
Donetsk and luhansk regions at the time
when they were part of Ukraine
in response U.S President Joe Biden
accused the Russian leader of setting up
a rationale to take more territory by
force
this is the beginning of a Russian
invasion of Ukraine as he indicated and
asked permission to be able to do from
his Duma so let's begin to uh so I I'm
going to begin to impose sanctions and
response
far beyond the steps we and our allies
and partners implemented in 2014.
a U.S satellite company has released new
images that claim to show military
vehicles massing in southern Belarus
even as Western Nations coordinate a
unified response many fear a full-scale
attack on Ukraine is still part of
Russia's plans
our Russian Affairs analyst Constantine
Eggert is following events from the
Lithuanian Capital Vilnius and joins us
now from there Constantine two-thirds of
the territory claimed by the separatists
is still held by Ukrainian government
forces but Vladimir Putin says that
territory doesn't belong to Ukraine
anymore is Russia going to help the
separatists take that territory by force
my suspicion is that first putting will
probably issue another ultimatum to uh
Vladimir zielinski the president of
Ukraine demanding that he settles the
outstanding issues with the government's
quote-unquote of the republics uh I
think that he hinted at that yesterday
when he said well Ukraine has an option
of settling uh this uh with with the
authorities of the newly recognized
entities uh maybe he'll do that and if
zelinski refuses which is 100 certain
that he will then I think a military
operation to help the new government
regain control of their territory will
begin and that will be probably the
first case since uh uh you know 2014 of
really massive uh uh eye to eye
confrontation between the Ukrainian
forces and the Russian forces because
the Ukraine forces do control as you
rightly said Terry the majority of the
territory which is clear by the
separatists and then yes
Constantine as you know the EU the U.S a
number of other countries the UK have
announced limited sanctions against
Russia in response to its latest moves
do you think those sanctions are going
to get moscow's attention
well frankly I think Terry the sanctions
that got moscow's attention actually one
point uh uh uh is the decision by uh
Chancellor Schultz to freeze uh the uh
certification sorry uh of North stream 2
guest pipeline this is very serious and
not only because it's probably 11
billion uh a lot by Moscow and building
it but because in the Credence eye an
important thing is for you to be ready
to suffer for your principles to be
taken seriously the rest of the
sanctions that you mentioned still do
not go up to that level although I would
say that the U.S sanctions uh which deal
with Russian sovereign debt uh and with
the children of some of the closest uh
Putin's allies some of the people in
Hisar to rush they hit closer to home
from the point you of the Kremlin the
sovereign debt look it will be much more
difficult for the Russian government to
borrow uh internationally at the time
when inflation is quite high in Russia
it's not
deadly but it's it's a complication and
uh as for the children of some of
Putin's collaborators that is a signal
as far as I understand it that other
people could on the line quite soon if
the Kremlin continues with the current
policies and I frankly cannot see Terry
how Putin stops now
we're looking at diplomatic
possibilities diplomatic options for
solving this crisis Constantine what do
you see as the possibilities what
leverage does the West what's what
leverage does Ukraine have to get Russia
to back off
I don't think that Ukraine has a lot of
Leverage unless there is an as I said uh
real confrontation real real fight real
war between Russian and Ukrainian forces
in Southeastern Ukraine and there
Russians suddenly feel that they're
defeated that is a possibility
theoretically but I would say that
um maybe the only chance is for the
sanctions pressure to become so high for
the sanctions to become so hard and so
outlandish in many ways uh that uh Putin
will concede and say okay I I will roll
back that is a very very faint
possibility but I can imagine in such
circumstances someone someone stepping
in as a symbolic mediator I don't know
the the former Charles America for
example but Frankly Speaking as it looks
now
um it's not even the chance not even
half a chance
Constantine thank you very much Russian
Affairs analyst Constantine Eggert there
well more Western countries have
announced sanctions against Russia as
mentioned the European Union Britain
Canada Australia and Japan have joined
the United States in targeting moscow's
access to finance so far the strongest
European reaction is Germany's decision
to Halt the key North stream to gas
pipeline on Tuesday Chancellor Olaf
Schultz announced that the
russian-backed project had been
suspended indefinitely
German Chancellor Schultz on his way to
announcing a key foreign policy decision
to Halt the highly controversial North
stream 2 pipeline in response to
Russia's recognition of two separatist
regions in Ukraine
the situation today is fundamentally
different and therefore in view of the
latest developments we have to reassess
the situation also with regard to North
stream too
Nordstrom 2 aimed to transport Russian
gas directly to Germany under the Baltic
Sea its construction was finished last
year and was pending regulatory approval
for a long time both Russian and German
leaders including Schultz in the past
had defended the project but it had
plenty of very vocal enemies
Ukraine has a start because it undercuts
its own Pipelines
but also the U.S and various EU
countries concerned it would give Russia
too much power and leave Europe
vulnerable those countries welcomed
Tuesday's decision with Ukraine's
foreign minister calling it morally
politically unpractically correct big
words of support towards the German
chancellor who had previously been
criticized for being too vague on the
North stream 2 pipeline
so we'll look at that pipeline a little
closer in just a moment but first let's
look at this some of the other sanctions
that have been imposed so far the
European Union has agreed to Blacklist
Banks involved in financing separatists
in eastern Ukraine and will also cut the
Russian government out of its debt
markets the U.S has imposed what it
calls a First Transit of sanctions they
target the so-called Russian Elites to
state-owned Banks and also seek to deny
the Russian government access to Western
financing and the UK has announced
sanctions on five banks as well as three
billionaires with close links to Russian
President Vladimir Putin Canada
Australia and Japan have also announced
measures
let's bring in Marcus Cena here he's a
senior fellow at the German Marshall
fund and previously worked as a foreign
correspondent in Russia Marcus what do
you make of the sanctions announced
against Russia are they likely to change
Russia's course
well as Constantine said uh it's very
unlikely that Russia really is going to
change course I think they've already
priced it in
um on the other hand we have seen that
the sanctions that were imposed after
the 2014 annexation of the Crimea during
the invasion in eastern Ukraine I think
they kind of were pretty much a surprise
to to Moscow because they didn't expect
the West to stand as unified as they as
they did now what's really important at
this time is if you look how those
sanctions were approved yesterday there
wasn't even a veto when it comes to the
EU from Hungary which always had a and
it had a different take when it comes to
uh to Russia so at this point we're
seeing a very unified front and a first
package of uh of pretty harsh sanctions
now Germany has finally halted the Nord
stream to gas pipeline as we mentioned
this comes after years of resisting
pressure to do so how do you think this
step will impact German Russian
relations
uh there was already a reaction from
Moscow and they were criticizing this
step so it's definitely going to have an
impact uh a negative impact on our
relationship I mean which is which is
something which is understood uh given
the money that has been invested already
we're talking about 10 billion or even a
little more than that that has been
invested in the in this project
on the other hand I think the German
government
um I mean also the previous government
was ill-advised to portray this pipeline
as a private kind of uh project I mean
it always had a very big political
component to it and I think you know the
ukrainians had also polls were very
vocal about it so I think it's just
natural that this is uh happening I I
personally would have wished that
Schultz would have made this
announcement a little earlier
what room Marcus do you see being left
for a diplomatic solution to this
conflict
well um if we see
um
regarding
um channels between
um talking challenge between Moscow and
the Western capitals uh this is not
really encouraging at this point we've
seen that um scheduled meetings between
the United States and Russia have been
called off at this point
um it's uh um actually it comes it came
to a halt the whole uh communication
between between Russia and and the West
uh there are definitely still back
channels here but uh what was I think a
very um disturbing was the fact that the
way Vladimir Putin was um was giving his
speech it looked like uh on Monday
Monday evening
it looked like he is in a bubble he's
kind of in a in a in a mindset that is
not really allowing much more room to
maneuver so I'm not really sure whether
Moscow is willing to keep on negotiating
Marcus senior senior fellow at the
German Marshall Fund in Berlin thank you
very much
thank you